let's keep on getting in trouble today
the Sun
has this report
scientists working on a fat loss pill
that doesn't require dieting have made a
major breakthrough in their research
baffins at the University of Texas have
been testing the game-changing drug
called
CPAC C so it's like CPAC with a c CPA CC
that Wards off weight gain on mice
experts hope that it will be
revolutionary in the fight against
obesity and it allows users to shed some
pounds without altering their diets in
theory people could scoff down as much
junk food as they like without the fear
of added health risks or not fitting
into their genes the Wonder pill
increases the body's metabolism to help
it break down sugar and fats more
efficiently
now of course
doesn't seem to be acknowledged in this
article but
the health risks from scoffing on junk
food gaining weight is only one of the
health risks it's not the only one
you know if you're eating fast food all
the time there's just there's not enough
nutrients in that it's not the right
kind of nutrients
and yeah it'll make you fat and so if
you take a pill that doesn't make you
fat anymore then you're not gonna be fat
that doesn't magically make McDonald's
healthy for you
which means that this is obviously a bad
thing right this isn't this isn't good
even if even if it would have some
positive impact
on an individual level
okay even if it would prevent individual
people from having heart attacks and
dying of obesity
because I would believe that you get a
pill like this on the market
there are a certain number of people
who without this pill
would would have obesity related heart
attacks
and now they won't because of the pill
and so you can make an argument that who
knows what the number is but it's like a
certain number of people that after this
pill goes to Market certain number of
people will will continue living whereas
otherwise they wouldn't
and so we might say well that alone
means that it's uh that's good what can
we say about it it's obviously good
and for everybody else it makes your
life easier and you feel better about
yourself and you feel better about
yourself when you look in the mirror and
you have a better self-image and
everything else that's all positive
thank you but it's not good
overall on a cultural level on a
societal level because it enables
self-destructive Behavior
which is bad for the soul
and it's bad for you as a person
and also ultimately self-defeating for
your physical health
in ways that should be intuitively
obvious
but we're not going to know all the
specifics until they start getting these
drugs and they already have drugs like
this ozempic you know
it's not quite this miracle drug but
it's it's the closest thing to the
miracle weight loss drug that's on the
market right now lots of people are
taking that
um
but as always with these kinds of things
so if you're at all you know an
intuitive person
and you hear about these these you hear
about any miracle drug you automatically
know that well there's there's really
actually no such thing as a miracle drug
there it just doesn't exist Miracles
don't exist in the form of a pill you
can't do that
um there are shortcuts there are things
that make your life temporarily easier
there are things that make you feel
better about yourself but there's always
a cost
that's the world we live in that's
that's life there's always a cost is
that dark spot on your face still
bothering you what about the liver spots
on your hands neck and chest well
they're bothering me so get rid of them
and now you can watch them disappear
safely and quickly in three quick
minutes introducing the genucel Dark
Spot Corrector they're three-step three
minute dark spot luxury system which
does exactly what it sounds like by
using their crystals microdermabrasion
before the Dark Spot Corrector and
finishing with a touch of the collagen
building genucel 15 you'll see the dark
spots disappear before your very eyes
instantly smoothly and luxuriously but
don't take my word for it if you're not
blown away with the results you get 100
of your money back no questions asked
free shipping and free returns all three
products are included in genucel's most
popular package for August so you you
get your Genius all bags and puffiness
serum also included for 70 off retail so
go to genucel.com Walsh order the new
dark spot treatment system today and say
goodbye to those pesky spots tomorrow
that's genusal.com Walsh there's no such
ring as a cost free
uh Choice especially not a cost free
drug
and intuitive people understand that
and so you already know that well no
this there's going to be it's it's not
all going to be roses here there's going
to be some problems that come from
and if you're a little bit more
intuitive but not that much you can
start
imagining what some of those
uh side effects are going to be
and one is that people are going to have
terrible diets like they do now
they're they're not going to get fat
because those diets and so there's
there's not going to be that immediate
incentive to change their diet and so
they won't change the diet but they're
still they still have diets that don't
have the nutrients that they need and
that have all kinds of uh chemicals that
preservatives that aren't good for them
and they're still ingesting all of that
stuff
and even it doesn't make it fat make
them fat
it
it will still have a negative impact on
their health in the end
and we don't even need to know what all
the specifics of that are with you know
we don't need to we don't need to wait
to find out
but we will find out because they're
going to get these jugs out there and
then they're going to be it's going to
have all kinds of horrible side effects
and there's gonna be a lot of suffering
that comes with it and then 10 years
later there's going to be all the
studies that come out and oh it turns
out
this that and this
um
and in the meantime
aside from the physical ramifications it
just again it it
facilitates self-destructive Behavior
it makes it easier for people to to
uh
to be gluttonous
and weak willed
and that's not good it's it's for the
same reason that Miracle drugs that are
meant to prevent STDs probably aren't a
great thing for society either because
they again exist to facilitate risky
self-destructive sexual behavior which
just means that you're going to get more
of it and while you have mitigated one
of the consequences of having a society
where everyone engages in this kind of
behavior you can't mitigate all of them
and for all the other consequences now
we're gonna have more of those
consequences because you've made it
easier for people to do this
and you've made it more attractive and
that's not good
what's better is that
okay you don't want to be obese
just go and just do some eat a salad
okay go for a jog because it's actually
it's not that hard to not be obese
um you don't want to get STDs
okay well then don't run out and have
sex with anyone you meet
okay meet a person be in a monogamous
relationship get married
be faithful
you know have Fidelity to your spouse
you don't have to worry about this not
something you have to worry about in
that case
so that's one way
and it is much better to have a society
where people
do that you know where they get married
that they're in monogamous marriages to
avoid STDs and they go for jogs and they
eat healthy to avoid obesity much better
to have that
I would say thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt Walsh show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts